so we've already started to familiarize
ourselves with the notion of charge
we've seen that if two things have the
same charge so they're either both
positive or they are both negative then
they are going to repel each other so in
either of these cases these things are
going to repel each other but if they
have different charges they're going to
attract each other so if I have a
positive and I have a negative they're
going to attract each other this charges
this property of matter that we've
started to observe we've started observe
of how these different charges this
framework that we've created how these
things start to interact with each other
so these things are going to these two
things are going to attract each other
but the question is well what what
causes so how can we predict how strong
the force of attraction or repulsion is
going to be between charged particles
and this was a question people have
noticed I guess what you could call
electrostatics for for a large swath of
recorded human history but it wasn't
until the 1600s and especially the 1700s
that people started to seriously view
this as something that they could
manipulate and even start to predict in
a kind of serious mathematical
scientific way and it wasn't until 1785
and there were many that came before
Coulomb but it said in 1785 Coulomb
formally published what is known as
Coulomb's law and the purpose of
Coulomb's law Coulomb's law is to
predict what is going to be the force of
the electrostatic force of attraction or
repulsion between two forces and so in
Coulomb's law what it states is is if I
have two charges so let me so let's say
this charge right over here a number
make it a white because it could be
positive or negative but I'll just make
a q1 it has some charge and then I have
in coulombs and then another charge q2
right over here another charge q2 and
then I have the distance between them
being R so the distance between these
two charges our goal is going to be R
Coulomb's law states that the force the
magnitude of the force so it could be a
repulsion a repulsive force or it could
be an attractive force which would tell
us the direction of the force between
the the two
charges but the magnitude of the force
which I'll just write it as F the
magnitude of the electrostatic force
I'll write the sub e here the subscript
T for electrostatic chrome stated well
this is going to be and he tested this
he didn't just kind of guess this people
actually were we're assuming that had
something to do with the sat the the
products of the the magnitude of the
charges and that as the part as the
particles got further and further away
the electrostatic force dissipated but
he was able to actually measure this and
feel really good about stating this law
he said that the magnitude of the
electrostatic force is proportional is
proportional to the product of the
magnitudes of the charges so I could
write this as q1 times q2 and I could
take the absolute value of each which is
the same thing as just taking the
absolute value of the product and here's
what I'm doing the absolute value of the
product well if they're different
charges this will be a negative number
but we just want the overall magnitude
of the force so we could take its
proportional to the absolute value of
the product of the charges and it's
inversely proportional to not just the
distance between them not just to R but
to the square of the distance the square
of the distance between them and what's
pretty neat about this is how close it
mirrors Newton's law of gravitation
Newton's law of gravitation we know that
the force due to gravity between two
masses remember mass is just another
property of matter that we sometimes
feel a little bit more tangible because
it feels like you know we can kind of
see weight and volume but that's not
quite the same or we can we can we feel
like we can feel or internalize things
like weight and volume which are related
to mass but in some ways it is just
another property another property
especially as you get into more kind of
fancy physics our everyday notion of
even mass it starts to starts to become
a lot more interesting but Newton's law
of gravitation says look the magnitude
of the force of gravity between two
masses is going to be proportional to by
the Newton's by the gravitational
constant proportional to the product of
the two masses actually let me do in
those same colors so you can see the
colors so you can see the relationship
it's it's going to be proportional to
the product of the two masses
1m2 it's going to be inversely
proportional to the square of the
distance the square of the distance
between two masses now these
proportional personality constants are
very different gravitational force we
kind of perceive this as acting being
stronger and so it's a weaker force in
close range but we kind of imagine it as
kind of what dictates what happens in
the in amongst the stars and the planets
and moons while the electrostatic force
at close range is a much stronger force
it can overcome the gravitational force
it very easily but it's what we can
consider happening at either an atomic
level or or kind of at a scale that we
are we are more familiar to operating at
but needless to say it's very
interesting to see how how this this
parallel between these two things it's
kind of this this you know these
patterns in the universe but what that's
it let's actually apply let's actually
apply Coulomb's law just to make sure
that we feel comfortable with the
mathematics so let's say that I have a
charge here let's say that I have a
charge here and it has a positive charge
oh I don't know let's say it is positive
five times ten to the negative three
coulombs so that's that's this one right
over here that's its charge and let's
say I have this other charge right over
here and it has a negative charge and it
is going to be it is going to be let's
say it's negative 1 negative 1 times 10
to the negative 1 coulombs and let's say
that the distance between the two let's
say that this distance right here is 0.5
meters so given that let's figure out
what the what the electrostatic force
between these two are going to be and we
can already predict that it's going to
be an attractive force because they have
different signs and that was actually
part of Coulomb's law this is the
magnitude of the force if these have
different signs it's attractive if they
have the same sign then they are going
to repel each other I know what you're
saying well in order to actually
calculate it I need to know what K is
what is this electrostatic constant what
is this electrostatic constant going to
actually be and so you can
measure that with a lot of precision and
we have kind of modern numbers on it but
the electrostatic constant especially
for the sake of this problem I mean if
we were to get really precise its eight
point nine eight seven five five one we
could keep going on and on times 10 to
the ninth but for the sake of our our
our our little example here where we
really only have one significant digit
for each of these let's just get an
approximation it'll make the math a
little bit easier I won't have to get a
calculator out let's just say it's
approximately 9 times 10 to the 9th 9
times 10 to the ninth 9 times actually
make my make sure it says approximately
because I am approximating here 9 times
10 to the 9th and what are the unit's
going to be well I'm in the numerator
here when I multiply coulombs times
coulombs going to get coulombs squared
this right over here is going to give me
that's going to give me coulombs squared
and this down over here is going to give
me meters squared this is going to give
me a meter squared and I what I want is
to get rid of the coulombs in the meters
and end up with just Newtons and so the
unit's here are actually their units
here are Newtons Newton and then meter
squared and that cancels out with the
meter squared in the denominator Newton
meter squared over coulombs squared over
over Coulomb squared let me do that in
white over over coulombs squared
so these meter squared will cancel those
those coulombs squared and the
denominator is example and encourage you
to pause the video and apply this
information to Coulomb's law and figure
out what the electrostatic force between
these two particles is going to be so
I'm assuming you've had your go at it so
it is going to be and this is really
just applying the formula it's going to
be 9 times 10 to the 9th 9 times 10 to
the 9th and I'll write the unit's here
Newton's meter squared over Coulomb
squared and then Q 1 times Q 2 so this
is going to be let's see this is going
to be actually let me just write it all
out for this first this first time so
it's going to be times 5 times 10
negative three coulombs x times negative
1 times 10 to the negative 1 coulombs
and we're going to take the absolute
value of this so that negative is going
to go away all of that over all of that
over we're in kind of the homestretch
right over here 0.5 meter squared 0.5
meters squared and so let's just do a
little bit of the math here so first of
all let's look at the units so we have
coulombs squared here then we have
coulombs times coulombs there's that's
coulombs squared divided by coulombs
squared that's going to cancel with that
and that you have meter squared here and
actually let me just write it out so the
numerator in the numerator we are going
to have so if we just say 9 times 5
times when we take the absolute values
just going to be 1 so 9 times 5 is going
to be 9 times 5 times negative 1 5 times
negative 1 is negative 5 but the
absolute value there so it's just going
to be 5 times 9 so it's going to be 45
times 10 to the 9 minus 3 minus 1 so 6 5
so that's going to be 10 to the 5th 10
to the 5th the coulombs already
cancelled out and we're going to have
Newton meter squared over over 0.25
meter squared these cancel and so we are
left with well if you divide by 0.25
that's the same thing as dividing by 1/4
what's the same thing as multiplying by
4 so if you multiply this times 4 45
times 4 is 160 plus 20 is equal to 180
times 10 to the 5th Newtons
and if we wanted to write it in
scientific notation well we could divide
this by we could divide this by 100 and
then multiply this by 100 and so you
could write this as one point eight zero
times one point and I don't want to make
it look like a more significant digits
than I really have one point eight times
10 to the seventh times 10
to the seventh news I just divided this
500 and I multiplied this by 100 and
we're done this is this is the magnitude
of the electrostatic force between
between those two particles and it looks
like it's it's fairly significant and
this is actually a good amount and
that's because it's actually good amount
of charge a lot of charge especially at
this at this distance right over here
and the next thing we have to think
about well if we you know if we want not
just so the magnitude we also want the
direction well they're different charges
so this is going to be an attractive
force this is going to be an attractive
force on each of them acting at one
point eight times ten to the seventh
Newton's if they were the same charge it
would be a repulsive force or they would
repel each other with this force but
we're done